hey superstar lineup including Brad Pitt
got together last night to pay tribute
at Chris Cornell the legendary rocker
took his own life
Brad Pitt dressed all in black
introduced the daughter of his late
friend Chris Cornell Tony Cornell's
tribute performance with Ziggy Marley
felt especially poignant through the
years we've watched father and daughter
share some sweet red-carpet moments
she's good she takes care she loves you
know people are you excited I'm
extremely proud Adam Levine also
performed at last night's benefit which
included 42 songs and lasted five hours
and another big moment Miley
[Music]
the singer wore two outfits one covered
in crystals including a drape two mini
dress priced just over 4 grand and knee
highs Saint Laurent boots that usually
go for $7,000 and yesterday before her
performance Miley shot down a report
claiming she and new husband liam
hemsworth were expecting miley fired
back on twitter saying quote i'm not egg
spectin but it's excellent to hear
everyone is so happy for us we're happy
for us too excited for this next chapter
in our lives
yeah let's give them a minute to be
married but before we put that enjoy
themselves right alright well back to
the tribute is eggs I think that the
benefit raised more than 1 million
dollars for two important organizations
including the crisp and Vicky Cornell
foundation
[Music]
[Applause]